people in east las vegas were able to
enjoy an early
cinco de mayo festival with a twist
today
it also came with a vaccine clinic eight
news now reporter victoria saha was
there
and takes a look at this new approach to
get more people vaccinated
this was a non-traditional way to
encourage residents in this community
to come out and get vaccinated making it
as easy as possible without any
appointment times all while celebrating
cinco de mayo
health officials say the east side of
las vegas was hit especially hard during
the pandemic
and as the push to get vaccinated
continues the county wants to make sure
everyone has a fair chance to a vaccine
along with their annual cinco de mayo
festival county commissioners made sure
a vaccine clinic
was right next door at bob price's
recreation center
so residents would not have to travel
far to get vaccinated
access to vaccines many don't have cars
so we tried to bring it right into the
neighborhood
so that it's available to them right
away the event had traditional mexican
food entertainment
and raffles this event aims to vaccinate
900 people reporting from bob price park
victoria saha 8 news now